hello I'm Lillian nice to meet you Lily  and I'm Kelsey nice to meet you you're  very energetic  oh thank you  appearance I would say the mocha with  raspberry syrup and caramel drizzle it's  kind of a fancier option and you're  dressed in a very fancy beautiful dress  thank you what's like your milk  preference  uh just like whole milk or cream what do  you like your coffee with do you like it  just like alone or like with food I  mostly just get my coffee to go just to  head to work or if I'm just going  somewhere I just want something a drink  so it's like mostly just like to to buy  something quick I'm gonna say black  coffee yeah  thank you